the game
where do we see the game going over the
next 25 years what do we see it evolving
to and so i'm gonna throw some things
out there just that i randomly put like
are we gonna move the three-point line
back
oh my gosh do we see that as a possible
option i can see ours moving back to the
nba one yeah see i can see it you see
the w
i think the line going gonna move back
you got guys like stephen curry pulling
up from half court yeah they got it they
got to change something
they can't move it back that's what i
mean you know we need closer
right but you would love to play with a
four-point line like y'all don't think
that's outside of like two you guys
people like troy young steph curry
pulling up pulling i feel like that's
gonna be people like tight a four point
play
you know maybe at the quarter mark
right at the half court that may be a
game changing
when i play if you shot s if you if your
team shot between six and ten threes a
game you were like you were getting them
up oh no now that was like you realized
she was 60 now what's up average 30 why
i don't know it's got to be how like 30.
warriors is getting 60 of them 50 to 60.
okay what about um
a shorter shot clock the game is moving
the game is going fast
i feel like now like the game's already
fat like
people are trying to get get buckets
quick and in shock first five seconds
first five seconds everything so why we
need a shot clock why we need 24 seconds
now
that's where the game needs to evolve
every level needs a shot clock yes
okay high school kids need a shot shot
because that helps you like if you got
the ball with five seconds what are you
going to there's games there's games
that i've watched in high school that
people hold the ball yeah yeah terrible
like they'll score and just hold the
ball we've had like people do the weave
yeah i was playing they would just be
weaving it off to each other
you'd be like
daddy
we did pilot in the 2019 all-star game
uh some changes like take the shot clock
from 24 seconds to 20 seconds it really
speeds the game up so those things could
always be looked at i don't i don't
think the three-point line but obviously
as technology and training and and
wearables you know uh come into play um
that that could be because obviously the
men's game has done that and the women's
game has moved that over over time but
um and i think we'll have some fun with
the 3x3 part of the game because 3x3 is
the number one most popular urban sport
in the world so we'll we'll pilot things
around that as part of our special
competitions but nothing
imminent on the actual on the court part
of the game because i i'm so pleased
with the quality of the game today
g-league right now in the g-league they
have you make the first free throw you
get two points
into the last two minutes of the game
next 25 years is this a part of our
league hey i think i think you need them
two free throws yeah cause i'm not gonna
lie
you you missed that first one you're
gonna need that second one that second
one could be big time for you it's
better for me especially in clutch
situations you only have to make one one
free throw instead of two when they try
things out in a in the g league in a
developmental league right sometime they
bring it up i like the mid-season
tournament though explain that what do
you like about it i like just the the
the competition of it and i feel like
you know the older teams like teams like
that they probably won't care you know
what i'm saying like we start this next
year the warriors probably don't care
about winning that they could care less
you know i'm saying they're trying to
shift when i say i think as younger
teams like that i feel like that can do
a lot for for confidence and and the
bonuses that you can get yeah like that
that can't that might not be something
to you know the top guy on the team but
like the 13th 14th man like
they doubling their salary you know what
i'm saying and it just creates more
competitive basketball that everybody's
gonna lock into because you know we get
to that point in the middle of the
season where it's like all right they're
a playoff team that they're not so we're
done the fans are not gonna watch as
much you know what i'm saying i'm
incredibly blown away by how thoughtful
adam has been
in the things he's thrown into the ether
this concept of a tournament in the
first part of the year i promise you
america's culture will shut down in
november december and focus on that i
mean the nfl needs to be worried about
that innovation think about the overseas
one well
probably get two points i feel like
that's gonna be tough
when you pass that pass through and you
get fired on that you know you get two
points i thought that would be a good
one all right no take fouls no take care
we gotta fix take fouls so if if it's a
foul they it's automatic free take on
fast break free throw and you get the
ball
and it takes that time we get more alley
we get more fun more excited more
excitement yeah i would like to also see
us
be able to knock the ball off the rim if
you know if it's in the phone you cannot
it changes the game from when i play to
now when you guys are playing it's a
different style it's a different way so
what elements that are happening in
today's game that you feel is going to
take over the game everything now is
dunks threes
and and like trying to trying to cross
somebody like everything every that's
all fans want to see nowadays is people
dunking alley use people making people
fall or d3s and stuff like
there was one play that went viral when
we was playing me and quick was on a
fast break me and uh emmanuel quickman
he was on a fast break
and he's at the he about to make the
layup yeah and he ran all the way to the
top of the key and shot at three i was
like damn i ain't really cheating
but i feel like i feel like that's
that's that's a big so threes are here
to stay for sure they're not going it's
gonna get worse what's the number one
thing in the game shooting the guys
range
is so it's amazing for me offense
is still about being exceptional
you have to be exceptional maybe at one
or two things but when we look at the
defensive side of the game
the defensive side of the game has
really changed
the league is going towards
switching everything like all screens
like defensively yeah like what y'all do
with the heat dude like i think teams
are trying to get more guys that can
guard one through five you have mobile
bigs you have guys that
uh are smaller that can guard a five now
and you have guys that are fives that
can guard a point guard and it went from
traditional
to now
traditional looks different when you
come to league you're gonna be expected
to guard every position you know i mean
and figure it out like i think uh the
the days of being in deep drop like
eventually that's gonna have to go
because dudes are just gonna be too good
you're getting hit by a screen you're
getting hit by a screen
because it's like it's the type of
player that's changing if you can't
shoot a three anymore especially in our
league like you have a problem yeah
you're gonna have a hard time like
staying on a roster so you have to be
like i feel like everyone looks like me
now like you're tall and long and you
can do a lot of different stuff but you
don't have centers anymore those are
phasing out
even point guards are getting taller you
want to do six eight
six nine
long after that corners like this that's
all they want with the burberry hat the
frog
thank you guys for tuning in to the next
25 hopefully y'all learned something
from us today hopefully i got a real
good look into the future thank each one
of you guys for coming in i appreciate
y'all appreciate you having me out
you